[Music]
emily what is going on
oh hey there how are you i'm good how
are you
yeah thank you so much for having me i
love your show
thank you i love that you love my show
that's so great what's going on how can
i help
um so i'm a military wife
and we're moving quite a bit this year
about like every four to six
months and it's starting to just become
a little stressful
so i was just wondering if you had any
advice on coping with being a new place
and moving jobs and all of that
you said that so i don't think you just
told me the truth emily
so you have to rephrase it in truthful
the way you would say it if you were
hanging out with a few of friends that
you've known for 25 years
if you've moved a few times this year
it's more than quote unquote a little
bit stressful
describe what it's like moving again
it's hard more
it sucks tell the truth there's no lying
on the show keep going
um i don't know i miss a lot of things
you know i miss my job and i miss my
friends and my family and
so
and more how do you feel about it
you're giving me some great military
answers
hello honey what is the mission for
today the mission is eggs and bacon like
how do you feel about it um
i i feel pretty sad what does that look
like
um well when you're in a new place
you know i used to be a teacher but i
can't really teach when we're only
in somewhere four to six months at a
time because you need to be somewhere
nine months
um so it looks a lot like me being alone
during the day
kind of trying to find things to do
you're telling me as though
you are on real world or real housewives
or something and somebody's watching it
i don't want to watch it i want you to
tell me how does it feel when you're
sitting in your house by yourself
in the third new city in one calendar
year it feels pretty hopeless sometimes
what does hopeless feel like um
pretty dark yeah like i i just don't
know what to do
lonely yes
very lonely exhausted
yes and then you spend all the time you
can
on your phone trying to connect with
somebody in some way and somehow
and you get these great ideas all right
i'm gonna go to the library or the
coffee shop and i'm gonna
and you get there and it's almost more
lonely because you're lonely in a
crowded room so you just go back home
and you watch something or text somebody
am i on the right track
um 100 yeah
who have you told this
um i talked to my husband about it a
little bit
and um i recently kind of called my
parents and told them
yeah how long have you been married
um we got married last july so get into
a year
okay and how long is this cycle gonna
last is this a season
or is this for the rest of your marriage
it's just it's a season um it's like
i mean we'll always move but usually
we'll be somewhere two or three years at
a time which i'm i'm like hanging on
until we get stationed my husband he's
in training right now
okay so we have live and six more months
six more months okay um we have one more
like six more month
move so i have four more months here one
more six more months
and then hope the plan is they put us
somewhere for two or three years
so you're you you have you have another
year of
having to be really flexible yes okay
is your um does your husband get to come
home or is he
off for four weeks at a time is he
coming home every day
nine to five yeah okay uh not nine to
five his schedule's different every day
and it's pretty very very long days and
then
you know he has to study for the next
day too so he he has a lot on his plate
right now yeah
but he's still home so that's nice well
so here's what i'm asking is
is there time that you can go spend a
few weeks in chunks
with former friends with people that you
care about
with your family yeah
i could for sure do that and i'm
thinking back
um i spent some time with some military
folks this week
um and we just talked about just offline
um not on stage just talked about
the the military spouses
are as involved as critical to the
military
functioning as the actual soldiers are
right as the actual
enlisted people are because what you'll
have to do is so so hard
um and they call it a sacrifice for a
reason it's really really hard
and in this season that you're in right
now every two to three years for me
sounds like a lot
um but every four to six weeks or every
four six months sounds just like chaos
right and yeah it feels a little chaotic
right now
there were seasons when the only i have
no comparison to what you're going
through so
i don't want to minimize what y'all are
experiencing but i remember when i was
writing
my dissertations or when i was working
on a book or working on a big project
there was times when i was
home yet completely unavailable i would
work all day
write all night and it became so
draining it became best for my wife and
even we had little kids
they would go spend a week with her
parents a week with my parents they go
visit friends
it allowed them to go have some fun
adventures to get some community
and it allowed me to totally plug in
because then i felt guilty too
and then all of us were just doing this
weird guilt
toilet bowl dance where we just i felt
like we were flushing
down the commode right is there some
ways you can get out and go see some
folks
because here's the thing if you were
moving here for two to three years
i would be really insistent you gotta go
first go
meet wives go get into the local
community go
be hyper intentional about making
friends and you're a teacher
you are great at helping new faces
feel safe and feel connected that's your
spiritual gift right that's that's like
what the cosmos gave you
um but man you're there for six months
you're gonna get just enough
relationship to feel sad when you have
to move again right
yeah and and i did try to get really
involved quickly when we moved here but
it's
i i know it takes about six months to
kind of start to get settled and
make like real friendships and stuff so
just in just for you just the time to
leave
with it yeah yeah you'll always have
this thing hanging over you
and so there's something about you got
to be around other people
and so going to have fun with other
people right if there's thing are y'all
living on base are you living off
we're off base right now okay um if
there's ways you can if there's things
you can do with the local church just go
have some but we
go have some fun if there's ways you can
get involved in a local ymca
you know all these things right because
you've looked them up and tried to
pretend you were going to do them even
though you're not
um yeah there's some of those things
that you've you can do and
look at those as opportunities to have
fun not an opportunity to make best
friends
right does that make sense yes there's a
difference there
and i want you and your husband to have
some real conversations about you going
and spending some time with your parents
go spend some time with some folks let
him study let him be all in
on this training and then when y'all go
move again
you can start getting settled right
is that making sense yes that makes a
lot of sense
here's the other more sense than what
i've tried to do well here's the other
thing
it's okay to be sad right now and i know
that sounds bonkers
but you're in the middle of a hard
season right and so
you may have heard me say this often but
just because winter shows up it doesn't
mean that summer's broken
it's just it means that it's winter this
is the season right now and it's not fun
it's cold it's miserable it's gray
sun doesn't come out um
and you just are in that season and
that's where you are right now
and so it's incumbent on you to own the
sadness it just sucks
i hate it i hate sitting in my house
alone and so
i'm then going to make sure i've got a
facetime
group not just a text group because it's
going to make you nuts i will
never ever check the news
because those things are built to spin
you out right i'm gonna go exercise
every single day i'm gonna go be around
other people not to make best friends
forever but just to have some fun
just we're gonna go bowling we're gonna
go to silly stuff we're just gonna i'm
gonna get together with some of the
wives and we're just gonna
complain and be loud and go fill
whatever whatever
right and what you're doing is there is
a little bit of passing the time there
is a little bit about you growing
this may be a great time for you to get
an online master's degree in a thing
right whatever that is how can you grow
yourself
so that in a year when you all land and
put some
roots in man then you're ready to rock
and roll does that make sense
yes that makes a lot of sense so some of
it's in a hundred percent of it's
intentional some of us just owning this
season
and i hate that for you and i hope that
everybody listening to this
man we talk a lot about um a lot about
this the sacrifices our service men and
women make and god almighty they do
let's not forget their spouses their
wives their husbands the folks who are
holding this thing together with string
and duct tape while they're
off training they're off on deployment
they're off
learning new things running night and
day and day and night
there is somebody sitting at home trying
to wrangle kids there is somebody
sitting at home
completely alone in a new town and then
a new town and then a new town
so if you know of community of people in
your community who are
transitioning or transitory or moving in
but be
really hospitable invite them over have
a dance party in your front yard have a
barbecue out in your driveway
be hospitable to folks who are new to
the neighborhood
who are just going to be there six
months everybody will be lifted up with
those interactions
emily thank you for your service
it's a winter season right now
relationally it's gonna warm up again i
promise
do the things intentionally they're
going to keep you healthy make sure
you're plugging in make sure you're
visiting people that you love and care
about
make sure you're being honest and open
about your feelings with your husband
and then y'all hang on there hang on
this season is going to come to an end
and there's going to be a place where
you can plant deep trees
that we're going to grow deep or not
deep trees drink plant trees that will
grow
deep roots